i'm basically filming like right up
until i get worse jacqueline may be busy
filming but her character steffy suffers
a shocking twist during a recent episode
you're crazy vin needs an ambulance
steffy do not make that call
you got some fun story lines right now
so we're diving into that before my
maternity leave so very very excited for
the viewers to uh they definitely need
to stay tuned because it's gonna get fun
one thing i love when i know that uh an
actress is expecting and that their
character is not pregnant is looking for
like
how they're hiding it like what they're
doing
in production to keep the things going
what's like the most creative novel fun
way that you guys have gone about hiding
your
pregnancy see i'm pregnant
but now your girl's not
it's funny because i speak with my hands
and
they'll say no no we can see your belly
so i have to like pocket a lot of it so
i'm trying to like cover the belly uh
but the cameraman and the director
they've been so great about like
covering as much as they can now you did
mention you're going on your maternity
leave congratulations on that how how is
the show and the story going to
like handle you being away well i have
no idea which how my storyline is gonna
go
but
oh my goodness
for the viewers it's it's just buckle up
because
there's gonna be a lot of twists and
turns right now
every day we're getting a different
script storyline things are moving very
very quickly so i really have no clue
but right now
it's like we're in the fit of it and the
viewers will find out very very soon